In this video I explain to you in a
simple way what the analysis of variance
is and how you can calculate it.
Strictly speaking, it is about the simplest
form of analysis of
variance, a factorial analysis of variance without Mesz
repetition and we start with
that, what do you need it for anyway  the
analysis of variance or
what does the analysis of variance do the analysis of
variance checks whether there are statistically
significant differences between more
than two groups
the analysis of variance is the
extension of the offender for independent
samples to more than two groups
in the test for independent
samples we looked at  whether there is a
difference actually a
mean difference between two
groups for example there is a
difference in salary between men
and women
in this case we had two groups
the men's group and the
women's group now if we
want to compare more than two groups
let's use those  analysis
of variance the addition to the test for independent samples
is equivalent to the
addition to the williams analysis without
mesz repetition in the test we
used the independent offender if
the two groups or samples are
completely independent, i.e. if a
person from this group is not related to
a person  in this group,
exactly the same applies to the
analysis of variance without mesz repetition,
except that we have at least three
independent samples. we would have a
dependent sample, for
example, if we interviewed
the same person in a test group at
several points in time,
then we would do an analysis of variance  use with
moderate repetition there
is a separate video for this
to make it all a little more tangible
let's just take a look at a
few examples of
a classic application for
variance analysis only in
therapy research that i might
be interested in, for example  whether different
therapies after a herniated disc result in
different
therapeutic successes you could test three different
therapies
on the one hand you could
only discuss with the patient which movements are
good and which movements are bad for the
intervertebral disc you could treat one group
with medication and with the
last group  could you do strength
training
after completing the therapy, you could
then measure the success of the therapy and evaluate it with the
help of a variance analysis,
with this you can then evaluate whether there is
a significant difference between
the three forms of therapy and
now another example from marketing me
as  Reasons from datatec could be of
interest if there are differences in
age between people who use
datatec SPSS or
he leads a
random sample and the person who
uses the statistics software and asks
the person which statistics software they
use  den and how old they are so i
have a group of people who use
databyte statistics software
a group of people who use spss
statistics software and a
group of people who use it as statistics
software
i would now like to know whether there is
a difference in these groups in the  age there
i only ever chose three different groups in both examples of
course there could be more but
what exactly is the question in
the variance analysis the question
is is there a difference in the
population between the
different groups of the independent
variable in relation to  the dependent
variable don't worry we'll go through the sentence
briefly you're
probably wondering why the population what is
the independent variable and what is the
dependent variable the independent
variable is the variable with the
different categories so in our
example it's the therapy type
with  the groups saved  Rächstherapie
therapy with medication and exercise therapy
or in the
other example, the independent
variable is the statistics
software used with the three groups date up
spss and he the dependent variable was
in our first example the success of the
therapy and in the second example
the age we would like to know  whether the
groups of independent variables have an
influence on the dependent variable
, so for our two examples
, the question would be
is there a difference between the
different types of therapy in terms
of therapy success or is there
a difference between the users
of different statistical
software solutions and the  dude
now the last point why
population we actually want to make a statement about the population
unfortunately it is not possible in most
cases to question the entire population
and we can only
draw a random sample
the goal is mi  t using the
analysis of
variance to make a statement about the population based on the random sample of course
we did not try to
determine the success of the therapy with all people who have a herniated disc
but only with a random sample
we would like to generalize the statement
for the total population
we need for that  the analysis of variance
therefore we use an analysis of variance
to check whether the result is
significant or not
now that we have understood that
we now move on to the hypotheses
before you can calculate an analysis of variance
you must of course make
hypotheses
in the case of the analysis of variance  is the
null hypothesis that there are no differences between the
mean values ​​of the individual groups
, so we have our
individual groups from which we can
calculate the mean value and
our 0 hypothesis is that there is
no difference in the
mean value in the population  native hypothesis
h1 is that there is a difference
between the group mean values
so that the mean values ​​in the
individual groups differ
well and good now we know what the
hypotheses are but what does that mean
now
let's say we want to check whether there is a
difference in the healed  between the three
groups, group 1, group 2 and group 3,
there is a certain spread in the salary of the person,
one person for
whom maybe 400 euros, another 2600
and another earns 6000
euros, both in the total population
and in our sample  the
salary is wide-ranging now the question is, of
course, where does this
fluctuation come from and can part of this
fluctuation be explained by the three groups
, i.e. how much of this
fluctuation in salary can
we explain by dividing the people into
these three groups
in the extreme case that could  result now
look like the salaries of group one
kö  If the
salaries of group 2 could be in this
range and the salaries of
group 3 could be in this
range, in this case
the division into the groups
could explain a great deal of variance in the variable salary
by dividing the groups
forms because in each individual
group we have a small variance while
we have quite a large variance overall
the result would look different in this case
here we would have
healed the variable again and would divide the salary
again between the three groups
but here we can use the  groups
explain almost no variance within
the groups we have almost the same
variance as in the original
variable accordingly whether we now form
these groups or
not we cannot explain any war completely if
we now look at the variance within the
groups then we can see
that  in this case we have a
very small variance  rhalf of the
groups have so within the
individual groups the person deviate
very little from the mean value on the
right side, however, we have a very
large variance within the groups the people
deviate very strongly from the
mean value of the respective group on
the other side when we  if we look at the
variance between the group means
then we see
that on the left we have a large
variance between the group
means so between the
group means we have a
large distance and a large spread
while on the right we have
between the means in  the groups have
a small variance so now of
course you want to know how you
can calculate an analysis of variance
there are two options for the calculation
either you take a
statistic software offers or you
calculate the variance analysis
by hand no one is
allowed to calculate the variance by hand  analysis by calculation
the wis  sen is still very
helpful to understand more precisely how
an analysis of variance works in
this video I will show you how you
can easily calculate the analysis of variance online
with data tab
but you are also welcome to watch my video on
how to calculate the variance analysis by hand
don't be afraid this slide
looks very complicated of course i will
explain in a simple way and
step by step how it works and
i will show you now how he can
easily calculate the variance analysis online for
this go to date
up de and click  on the statistics
calculator
would you like to use your own data
please put them on the table teachers
and then copy your own data into
this table
I'll just use the example
actions because we want to calculate an analysis of variance
just click
on this tab now let's just select
the  variables from which we
want to examine we need for the variance analysis
a metric variable and a
categorical variable with at least
three values ​​i'll just click on
the income and the
nominal variable location because
in this example the nominal variable location has three
values, namely vienna zurich and
berlin, now calculated and
automatically stages a variance analysis,
admittedly the prerequisite
will certainly not be fulfilled in this example
but you can also calculate the
non-parametric variant of the analysis of variance just as well
if your data are
not normally distributed
but we will stay with the
analysis of variance for now so you will
not get any results down here
the levin will soon be here  the variance equality test is
calculated and below you can see
the results for the variance analysis
here you can read the ph value
if this value is greater than 0.05 the
new hypothesis will be retained
otherwise it will be rejected
you can also simply view the
summary  sung in words
here you get the result
interpreted very simply 1 1 facto rial
variance analysis has shown that there is
no significant influence between
the categorical variable location and the
variable income so if you like
you can watch the video on
the requirements for
look at the analysis of variance or you look
at how to calculate the analysis of variance by
hand
bye and see you next time